[موسيقى]
ابني اللي ما خلفتهوش
عايزه تروح من دماغي ابدا
[موسيقى]
جعفر مش بالعالم بتاعي
ولا انا من العالم بتاعي خالص
[موسيقى]
في رمضان اسماء ابطالها بمعنى يعني ان
المسلسل ياتي باسم ابرز بطل فيه مثلا
مسلسل جعفر اللي عنده بطوله محمد رمضان
مسلسل رشيد بطوله محمد ممدوح مسلسل الكبير
بطوله احمد مكي ومسلسل جميله بطوله ريهام
حجاج
[موسيقى]
شفت المصيبه اللي احنا فيها انا ابتديت
مشوار
باسماء شخصيات ابطالها لكن بشكل غير مباشر
على سبيل المثال هناك مسلسل رمضان كريم
حيث يلعب سيد رجب شخصيات رمضان ومسلسل
يتسليمه حيث تلعب دنيا سمير غانم شخصيه
سليمه ومسلسل عمله نادره حيث تلعب نيللي
كريم شخصيه نادره ومسلسل وعود تحيه حيث
تلعب حنان مطاوع شخصيه السخيه وهو امر يجد
النقاد اذكى والطف وقعا على المشاهد ساعات
كتير بيبقى اسم الفيلم او اسم المسلسل على
اسم بطله او على اسم الشخصيه الرئيسيه فيه
ازاي الشخصيه يتطور وبتروح فين في ذكاء في
ده والساعات كتير بيبقى استسهال بس ده مش
الحاله العامه الحاله العامه بتبقى هي ان
انا ببني شخصيه مهمه قوي في الدراما فعشان
كده عايز اسمي الفيلم باسمه
المفروض الاسم المسلسل يكون على السيناريو
بتاع المسلسل او الاحداث عامه لو اسم
الشخص
مثير للفضول في المسلسل اكيد هيسير فضول
الناس اكثر بكثير من اسم الشخص يعني بفضل
اسم المسلسل ويكون اكثر غموضا اكثر
بالنسبه لي الاسم مش هيفرق طبعا المحتوى
هيعجبني وجذب الناس المحتوى اهم حاجه
المحتوى
[موسيقى]
عمر
يا عمر يا عمر
يا عمر
والله
ما شفتش عمر